it's it's important to mention that the
the mainstream narrative the mainstream
media they're tumbling they're fumbling
they're falling apart and we got this
story from yahoo news
january 6 committee lawmakers devastated
by jeff zucker's ouster from cnn this
one's just a really amazing story
because apparently
cnn employees are freaking out that jeff
zucker gets get you know he gets
basically ousted the new guy who's
apparently
one of the largest shareholders and i
think it's called uh from liberty media
which is a larger shareholder in
discovery discovery who is then taking
over cnn is a large trump donor so the
top level cnn staff are all freaking out
and they're saying in these meetings
that i've spoken with the january four
members of the january 6 committee and
they're devastated this is happening why
are they devastated because we learned
from rolling stone that at the highest
levels of cnn they were colluding with
andrew cuomo a democrat governor to help
him craft his covet narrative they were
talking about this guy being a
presidential candidate at the time and
cnn was helping him chris cuomo was
helping his brother and i think that's
why the whole scandal erupts chris cuomo
helps his brother know zucker's helping
his brother then when he gets busted
zucker says you're fired chris cuomo
goes you were doing the same thing and
he's like too bad and he's like well
then pay me out my contract and zucker's
like i ain't paying you out your
contract and then chris says i will oust
i will get you fired i will i will tell
everybody about your relationship with
this woman and then he does and now the
whole thing's imploding and falling
apart but you know what we see from this
it's uh it's becoming clear and clear
out in the open in the mainstream press
cnn was colluding with democrats for
favorable press coverage we always knew
it because it was obvious anyone paid
attention but now it's definitive and in
print we can see it that's that's why
they want to censor everybody else so
they can get away with stuff like that
my conspiracy senses are tingling
because i definitely do not believe that
zucker went down because of an affair
that people knew about for years katie
couric was even talking about i think
there's something bigger at play here
and i think there is some kind of
vengeance from the como's the como's are
a very powerful family politically
especially
decades and decades ago especially with
the power that they had in new york and
the the political sphere uh a long time
ago but uh when it comes to cnn
obviously people are realizing that this
is not journalism this is not news this
is pr for special interest special
interest pay them support them and they
do their bidding no matter what and
they're willing to cross any line
they're willing to violate any kind of
morality in order to help the people
that pay them and this is essentially
the big business of corporate media
that's exactly what it is it's nothing
else it's not even media it's propaganda
could it be a could it be that the i'll
sit um because of some flights he took
to a certain island
we don't know if zucker was uh i haven't
seen any direct uh evidence about that
but i wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case i'd not heard that he had been
on those planes no no i haven't heard it
either but it's kind of no i think this
is more you're right it's not more than
just an affair yeah i think it's that
they were colluding with democrats the
the the most trusted name and news
working with democrats for favorable
coverage is a massive probably one of
the biggest media scandals in this or
there could be a bigger story coming out
about their direct involvement um that
they're trying to of course save face on
and to of course
not get a big backlash on and that's why
they're stepping down preemptively there
could be something even bigger coming to
light soon but why would the uh i know
that you still have to finish reading it
but why would the gen generate six
committee
uh
be devastated because
then is is basically their mouthpiece
they're trying to come out with this lie
they've they've been trying to come out
they've been screaming the lie for a
year about january 6. it's quite simple
january 6 was bad a lot of people fought
their way through that front tunnel and
fought with cops fought their way in the
front of the capitol really really bad
bad riot a lot of these people had the
doors opened for them by the police cnn
wants to push the insurrection narrative
because they are helping democrats they
are now being exposed their own
president
colluding with democrats the woman he's
having an affair with worked for cuomo
so when they come out and they're like
it was an insurrection and then you get
these democrats saying we're going to
file a lawsuit because anyone who spoke
at that rally was involved in
insurrection is no longer eligible to be
a public official
cnn is helping them do that and they got
caught that's why and that's why they're
devastated they're like oh no our whole
mission to to defraud the american
people well they're the whole narrative
depends on the mouthpieces cnn is the
mouthpiece of their narrative that
they've been pushing and obsessing about
to the point where they have been losing
90 of their audience they have been
working so hard at doing the bidding of
the special interest that they're losing
everyone and and
it's not a surprise why people don't
watch them why people don't trust them
because it's it's clearer than ever
they're not in the business of news
they're in the business of power and i
think uh i think you would agree with me
enrique that the january sixth uh panel
is about power as well no no it's about
truth they're trying they're trying to
find out what happened january 6.
man
it's really it's really crazy to watch
this past month
how the establishment seems to be
collapsing at an exponential
exponentially increasing rate
yep and
are we does this mean that we're going
to see now um
because this would be complete twilight
zone we're going to see more right-wing
cnn now this is crazy because apparently
this guy john malone i think his name is
he owns this company called liberty
media i think faction man this one i
think it's called liberty media i think
that's what he owns and they're like a
quarter
25 shareholder of discovery discovery is
basically buying
time warner or something like that like
warner media which owns cnn so
ultimately you get this dude
who apparently he's been very critical
of jeff zucker
he said he wants cnn to be impartial
this was three years ago
now he's going to have some of the
biggest uh the most voting power in the
company that basically owns cnn
and a lot of people are speculating now
it's going to go either like middle of
the road or center right or something i
i doubt it i think that with the staff
that they've hired they've already
created that culture
within their whole um within the whole
culture within cnn
um and i think that what's gonna happen
is you're gonna see i don't know i don't
know if they're like unionized or
whatever but you're gonna see like a big
push
if if he wants to take it in that
direction i
i i disagree there there's the veritas
release where there's this like this
producer guy and he's like i remember
when we were would report the news
now it's just all trump all day i mean
there are people who work there who are
upset that they work at this job that's
become this trash
in this private meeting you had people
like jake tapper jake tapper said if it
wasn't for zucker the network would have
become benign vanilla gruel
what's the news supposed to be chocolate
sprinkles no it's supposed to be benign
vanilla gruel it's supposed to be your
it's supposed to be your vegetables you
know when i was a kid seinfeld and the
simpsons that was dessert
but the but the but the vegetables was
the news i was like you this is your
five o'clock news on fox 32 and it was
boring and i was like and then as soon
as it ended the simpsons came on i was
like all right the simpsons
what do they think cnn is supposed to be
it's supposed to be news but zucker is a
reality tv guy a deeply deeply evil man
who turned politics in this country into
a spectacle for profit
and he destroyed the network there's
another story from the rap private text
messages from former employees of cnn
saying zucker destroyed the network and
he did and now that he's leaving jim
acosta i think it was said we would be
something like fox news light
fox news light does that mean centrist
yo because it's probably what's seen in
support like should have been wasn't
there a fox news reporter that like quit
live on the air
fox news reporter i don't know yeah i
think you've had her on the show every
hacker
yeah oh yeah but that was crazy
yeah
that was stunning i hope more people do
what she did because
because they told her that they didn't
want to report stories because certain
racial groups didn't care about these
stories
i think she wanted to report on bitcoin
was that what it was i don't remember
that was it big details of it i think it
was something like that and they were
like you know this particular racial
group doesn't care about that so we're
not going to report it and it's like
well you know
to be honest i understand the point
they're making we run a business but at
the same time if your news is predicated
upon what you can sell to the masses you
become cnn and that is a problem it's a
fine line but you know the
we used to have a news
or maybe we never did maybe
maybe we never did yeah this independent
journalism i think is the way it's
supposed to be
what we got now like we are change and
tim gaston's well that's i mean that's
the future that's less people are tuning
into mainstream media more people are
tuning in to like podcasts alternative
media um and i think it's just gonna get
worse and i think these networks are
gonna are gonna suffer the problem is
with independent media is how do you
verify they're not a crackpot is that's
challenging you kind of gotta like peer
review them no no you just you just have
to only watch the shows where people
speak a certain way like they talk like
this if they speak like this and you
know when referring to what happened in
uh liechtenstein that's another credible
and they have suits and they have
paychecks from bill gates then they're a
hundred percent incredible suits and
absolutely trustworthy but but if they
talk like this guys really fast like
okay gang you know we got to talk about
what's going on to risk no yeah you
can't trust them i'll enjoy the anarchy
yeah but what's up but ian to answer
your question what independent media
does what joe rogan does especially with
his long format three-hour long
conversations which from any kind of
business perspective if you would have
asked a media guy like is this going to
be successful they would say no but why
is it successful is because you're taken
along a journey of experiencing and
exploring and finding things out not
through an agenda or a narrative or
something that has already has you know
a final
plan of what you think it is it's an
exploration so when we have an
independent media we have sharing of
data of information and conversations
and debates that you would never have on
the corporate media that question
everything in our reality and that's why
it's so much better and stronger than
the corporate media trash that they feed
and shove down our throats you see
a while back people started complaining
that the news was turning everything
into sound bites that instead of talking
about politics it was just a five minute
clip on the tv
then twitter comes along and there's
this video glenn greenwald shared from
09 where he said i think it's a problem
that twitter has his character limit and
it's going to keep you know
reducing our conversations and and
making it you know making it worse off
now what's happened we've we've we've
punched that that rubber you know we
stretch that rubber band to the point
where it can't go any further and
snapped back
and now we've gone from the two minute
sound bite to the three-hour long-form
podcast conversation as the media choice
for so many people so cnn
their old guard their you know fox news
they're like tim would you like to come
on the show we'll give you two minutes
and i'm like nah no thanks dude
jordan peterson was four and a half
hours on rogan this last one and it was
totally fine i only saw the first 40
minutes so far i was driving it was
already florida i watched all of it it
was amazing it's very tough so who's to
say how long is it going to go it might
not even matter at this point like
length maybe isn't the the problem it's
authenticity and an ability to flesh out
ideas so people can wrap their minds
around it instead of a guy coming out
and being like antifa is bad and uh vote
trump bye
like you know hold on let's slow down
and say you know you've got people then
saying yeah but trump is bad no no we
get that like when you have long-form
conversations you can say things like it
was bad that trump bombed syria but it
was good that trump tried to get our
troops out of afghanistan and set the
deadline for the withdrawal and then joe
biden flubbed it you can get into all
the details around it and the nuances
the true the truth is nuanced right it's
not black and white there's a lot of
gray there's a lot of exploration
there's a lot of things that you have to
come to an understanding of by patiently
hearing both sides of the story the only
way you could do that is through of
course long formats instead of two
minute segments thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you